what's the number of words in my heart?
what's your name?
is that actually my heart rate right now?
hold on a minute
is that actually my heart rate 102?
I'm not even doing anything yet
I'm not even doing it
I'm sure that is 102
I can feel my heart rate is 102
damn I'm dying
very slowly but I will
good morning
good evening
that's how you're going to feel body shot
hey hey hey
right we're playing
focus focus
there's a pizza on my ring foot adventure
I'm standing up right now
in my brand panty loons
uh
but we've got a bit
oh whisper it cause we've got a soul of war
a bit of a small update
I lost the thing I am supposed to attach to my leg
so I have take like body take
I don't know if you can hear that
so we're going to have to go in game
in order to correctly apply
what I need to do to my leg
it's a bit skull congrats on 14k
me and the girls got twice
cults twice yesterday
um I know
hold on I completely forgot how to use Nintendo
I don't play it
okay I heard that
hopefully that wasn't too loud for you
damn get the fuck out of my head
good morning good evening good afternoon
I'm so sorry I'm a bit scattered today
um I'm
very familiar with the game of Nintendo
um
I'm sure the switches are very serviceable
console and all that jazz
but oh my god
I've been so long
since I've
it's literally been an entire year
and then some change since I've touched this
right okay
that I am missing the orange
band I am using
tape
so this is going to be very interesting
are you squidding me right now
what are you saying
strongly feet my beloved
oh the feet is what you're wanting hold on
I need to like wrap it around my leg
to guesstimate how much thigh
right where is it
wanting me it's actually wanting it above my knee
but you know that hold on right
we've cut the strip
this stuff is good this stuff is good
I promise if I was
a face streamer you'd be absolutely loving
the viewer right now
this is just all my thigh hold on
I'm trying to take the back end off of the
tape
oh no
tape my biggest enemy the back
of the tape is not coming off
oh come on
wait I'm messing it up in that corner
hold on let me down your corner
I am new well you're in for a wild
raid for the first streamer exercising
I'm going to be making
I literally had to tell my dad
I was like I'm playing an exercise game
whatever you hear you do not hear
okay sorry but this is a fan service game
I don't care what anyone claims
or says this is pure fan service
and I am happy
oh
did I time out
this is error YouTube is not
receiving my signal
why not YouTube
can you guys still hear me
testing
three five five
what kind of
you
well I'm in brand
panties so you know we can put the rest
together
how may we serve you
today cut a fish over lord by taking
the back of this plaster off or you see
I literally can't get the bandage
thing off are you serious
no wait this is what stops the stream
sorry I'm so in love
with your body
yeah
you like the skinny
waist
well actually I do have boobs in this form
but then
you can still hear me but
I'm a little choppy
oh my god I actually can't get in the
back and off of this I'm not being funny
it's not doing the sticky side thing
bruh get sticky
get sticky
I literally cannot take the backing off the thing
we're stuck
we're literally progress whole
edge because the back of this freaking
table come on
I'm about to look
and I think my heart rate
I just realized
I think my heart rate is not
are you squidding me right now
oh my oh in the
ah
you better not be in your garage
what's your way
of choice absolutely no way for
me mate
I'm sure you know that much thank you big
for the super chat and thank you Spidey
for showing me my bulletin
where the fuck is my heart rate at
wait
isn't it all gonna work in the background
no way
I can't use this app in the background
and use Vtube Studio at the same time
I've completely fubbered up the stream
that's true
says it's reconnecting
that made sense does it why is my heart rate
continually 102 I promise you
I'm talking a lot it's not gonna be one of
two have I completely
messed up the stream
I swear it again
oh and it just turned out
you're not even trying
are you even trying
right I've got
the bandaid
insert
the joycon into the left
pocket yes we totally have that
it doesn't even
work with my device my heart rate monitor
it's just fucking giving up
right I'm 130 oh Jesus
that is unhealthy are you joking me
okay 123 and if I
close the app I'm guessing
it's gonna just bug out and not
change from that number
lovely right well I've completely
oh no
oh I must have disconnected because I went for a pee
okay okay not bad
right next next insert
the joycon onto your left leg or something
like that okay so it says left
the eye strap so I'm just gonna try and place
it where it is yes I
am using tape yes
it's scuffed yes I'll take
a photo after stream if that's what you want
you can get anything you want
little reeflings and insert the joycon
into your pocket it's already inside baby
you didn't know what kind of stream this was
okay is there a strap
via this fucking
contraption I've made at home
okay
oh
oh I've
registered it's
working reeflings it's working
oh wait
okay
oh you can see
oh my god you can see my homemade leg
strap look at that speed
hit him with a twerk you don't know
if I'm twerking right now
oh my god this is so killer you can see
me I cannot wait until 3D
I'm sorry it's over for your technical
when we hit 3D press in and start
why is my thigh
no my thigh is straight
oh my god
my thigh is getting hot
yeah I don't have much strength
we aren't doing strength that's all I'm saying
hold on let me take a sip of water after that bad boy
we're in we did it
okay I'm taking some water
and before anyone's panicking
like 106 here you may go beast
no I just have really fast
hyperactive heart relax
it's just how it is and I won't go too far
don't worry
ring fit con basic controls hold the ring fit con
so that the top surface of the joint con
faces you okay it is
confirm in cancel out move cursor
okay confirm
I press in health and safety yes
he says that does
barely 160 exactly
right we're gonna do quickly
a quick way to get into some casual fitness
games yes
we're not gonna be
going crazy
wait it has like things that
yeah I'm gonna do this
have I played all these
I don't think so
we'll play through all the minigames and see where that takes us
if I'm not completely dead in the water by then
let's just do novice
press rotate press
and pull the ring con and hit the robot
mr. locator robot
actual critter heart beat
should have been a hamster beecher
confirmed I can't believe it
I can't believe it
you have yourself plenty of room to play me who's
currently wired right now and cannot hear the game play
well if I took my hands off I couldn't hear it
but and I've got my chair right here
that I'm gonna hit
really
now you want me to do a venture
are you sure
I was just gonna do many games because it's a
two hour stream unfortunately
you can see the screen capture
with R of our justice
stand with your feet and shoulders apart
point the ring
okay
rotate left and right
yeah got it
oh that was actually a part of the mission
okay
oh I can't do the pull out oh my god my wrist
did not like the pull out
that's what she said
um smash the robots
oh god
I already done my work out for the day
hamster stroney wouldn't have technicals true
your heart is powered by a car engine
do whatever it's all good for you
okay I'm glad let's go
ready yeah
there's nothing on screen oh my god I was
no other way other way in
oh my god I can't
do this kind of thing in my head
I did stream why am I getting told off
by a freaking video game
cause I've never been told off by a video game
the absolute audacity
multiple muscles
are you done oh my god I can't do that
pull it's too hard
oh
oh my god
oh my god stop
this is actually been terrible
stop giving me the out ones I don't have
own strength
oh my god I don't have
oh there's more no no
no I don't have
that kind of strength I cannot do that
I'm sorry I need to change the freaking
insider insider
strength stop
oh I can't do it
it's my heart rate okay I don't know
I can't oh my god this is terrible
game play
thank you Nero for the extended membership
please don't die on stream I'll try my best
okay
oh my god are you
squidding me right now
my heart is pumping
that was terrible
no heart rate
very much not okay
can you get a heart rate check heart rate check
no it's done check thank you demon
for the extended membership
I really believe in you
I believe in you and you also get really
for me good
VTubers only weakness
physical activity
it's because I'm not freaking exercising
I can't squid me right now
are you joking
Sylvie on the lurking weflon thank you
weflon as in teflon
the thing that doesn't stick in pans
thank you for the extended membership
I appreciate you greatly
really helps
okay so finished
oh my god
what was my heart rate record there let me
type it in
now that we're trying to like give ourselves a heart
attack well I mean
it would be cool to see what my record
is
hold on what was heart rate record
you hit some heart rate
record
177 and that was just my
arms that's how bad I am with my arms
so wait until we actually do
like a leg one where the blood flow gets
pumping
everybody's jumping
everybody's moving
passersby rings your candle
and closing the parachute
sure
I'll play this one
what heart rate monitor are you using
I am using
plusoid in combination with
cost pool
stand with your feet
with the part raised both arms
not an arm one again please
I can't handle arm ones
are you squid me or not
thank you for talking with them
what is this
tilt to the right
sorry G
tilt to the left
tilt forward
so I hit that
like sheesh I can tell
you're trying to get me to pull it
oh my god
I'm to pull it out and do this
try to fall through the rings
oh my god I'm going to be perishing
are you serious pull it yeah
wait I can see the first thing
down here
yeah you know what else is nice
and white
not my clamps
oh my god this is so sore
I'm not being funny
this is terrible
this is awful
for my perla
weak wrists
I think I'm going to beat my records
in this
no no no I literally
purposefully draw
work on my form
are you serious this is so sore
I'm not playing the arm once again
this is awful
can I just drop in the way
stop I'm cheating I'm actually cheating
no
okay okay
cheaters never prosper or something like that
I don't know
oh my god I actually don't have the strength for this
I genuinely my arms are trembling
my arms are trembling I'm having to
cheat
I can't do it my arms are trembling
I'm going to no
oh my god
oh don't ever make me do
that one again you don't
oh my
I'm sitting down after that with my heart rate
it does not feel good after that one
I was having
a pump of blood above my freaking head
brrr
I'm just steering disrespect
I'm literally on the floor
wait are you tracking me right now
okay
oh I forgot to say
finish
please give me a leg workout
that's all I ask
right I'll do sport
oh I forgot to do a warm up
oops
I forgot to do a warm up
actually
maybe I should have done a warm up
wait hold on let me do a quick stretch
I'm now circling
my arms to stretch
I'm now leaning forward
I'm now leaning back
and then I'm leaning
a little to the right
and I'm leaning a little to the left
and then I'm putting my hips in a circle
throw them hips
in a circle
okay there we go
I'm doing, I'm lifting my knees up
I'm lifting my knees up
I know I can't do tippy tippy here
I'm not all I'm going to say is 3D me
and Ring Fit Adventure
it's over
them hips
yeah I like my hips
are they tantalizing
I felt everything
alright anonymous thank you for the tip
I think all the refunds would like to
see you work out your thighs
show us how to prepare for the club
no hands I swear
and I want to see the little senior in the gym
would make so many scrawny little refunds
want to bulk up to impress you
aww
that one
I like fat men
I don't want to
I don't want a skinny barbie
I want a fat barbie
jump to collect the tokens as they pack
that's fine the lord, yeah that's fine
we can do squats
all I'm saying is that my legs are prepared
well it's been a while but
right what am I doing
unbend your knees and extend your legs
point the ring clock, yeah that's all good
to jump
okay
yeah this is bending me
to jump slowly
okay
oh bend so you don't hit the balls
wait what bend slowly
so you don't hit any balls
what
to jump slow
oh that's what I wanted
I didn't want me to jump
okay thank you Kono for becoming a member
collect all the tokens
you can touch the bomb bar
ready
go
I don't
okay I like squats
I can like literally try hard this
I'm not even kidding
this is easy to feed the lemon
thank you again for Kono the member tip
actually refling
I've got two things with you
don't hit the bombs or you'll lose points
oh shit okay
oh no I missed it
oh no
what
I'm just so good at squatting like this
this exercise uses a wide range of muscles
yeah
I mean I can tell
I'm using them
no not the ball
I just missed the ball
I'm not even kidding
keep it up
I'm keeping up
I'm doing the best I can
I like this one
wonderful
more more more more more more more more
yeah
I like that one
what do you mean I like the one that I'm good at
I'm good at
what do you mean I like the one I'm good at
yeah record that record
gonna be adding the girls
soon
and then it can be like oh my god is that Strony's thighs
and I'm like here he is it's Strony's thighs
try to hydrate in between
each friend though
yeah
how about my heart rate
did I beat my record yet
then I beat my record
I'm a hundred and of seven seven
it's one seven three
no I need to beat my record
I think we'll be running
if I want to beat a record
no not retry oh no
oh fine right
lock in boys lock in lock in
we'll do a second one
I don't mind
it's really hard to tell what's too much
and what's not
I'm just doing my thing
I'm just jumping away
sorry I didn't mean to do it again
but I'll do the next one don't worry
wait I can hear music
cause it's got words in it in the background
alright we'll grab them but then we won't go max
we won't go max
what no no no
sorry sorry
I missed it oh I'm so fast
I got so shy to jump
I just like stopped
okay just a little bit
I'm trying
I love this slide it's so cute
I got it
maybe I can beat my record
I didn't beat it I beat it
I beat my record
oh yeah I beat my record
hell yeah record that are you joking
record this
what did I get 180
let's go
hard
record
Johnny that's not a good thing
now cause if you work your heart out
it's good for you
now do it with one leg
I can't actually do it
you guys please
it's supposed to be the record in game
not your heart beat
that's so true
you shouldn't get your heart that high
alright fine I'll sit on the floor
and then we'll pick
crate, crash or whatever that is
I bet you'll be another arm one
they're all freaking arm ones
will you pheromone max
after this or take a shower
unfortunately I have to take a shower
cause my dad's still here
like see send in
or do drop my heart rate by like there
why did it just go up why is it going up
why is my heart rate going up
I'm sitting down
stop
stop going up
actually just do it with no legs
she's not a masochist
she just wants to know how much she can take
wait until we do the next arm one
I'm just gonna check
okay this still looks secure to me
my little contraption looks pretty secure
we don't want a heart attack on stream
I mean that's luck
more tea more squats high score
saw about Inkin and got
and got her little heart going steady
on that was yesterday's stream
I shouldn't be surprised
she's so good at squatting
yeah do you believe in the buns
do you believe in the cake that's coming at you
you just wait until donathan
you will not
you'll be sick of my ass
right fire, air blast
and break as many crates as you can
before the time runs out
thank you horror mist for becoming a member
and supporting
two things we need to do is pick out our missing emotes
and I need permission to make
a short because
I need to make sure you guys are okay with it
if you're not okay with it please do tell me the truth
and I will not make the short
wait why is it not centered
that's not center
hold on
when we're done if you hit a balloon create nearby
a blue small
not another arm one
to re-center
okay that's exactly what I needed
I'm okay with it
you don't even know what I'm going to try to make
Kaidon
stay up late last night to watch the VOD
of the supermarket simulator
and laugh my ass off
was I sleep deprived
yes was it worth it
absolutely looking forward
to more streams
thank you Kaidon for the super chat
and thank you for your super chat cherry
give me all your man cherries
yes I'm ready
wait hold on I've done wrong
what I hate okay we're not doing arm ones
this is awful
this is awful do the bomba
bomba bomba bomba
I am holding it up
this park is harassment
okay I am holding it up
stand
great effort
I'm trying
I'm not going to make it
okay we've got ten thousand I'll take it
oh my god this is so hard
oh jeez that was cheating more than that was
awesome
oh please
I can't do that one
oh we've got 15 thousand on the
that was rank B
who is playing this game
I guess rank A so easily
oh my
oh my lord
that's exactly what I should do the arm ones
because I'm a weakling
no I want to remain a weakling
and then you do everything for me refling
okay I want you to
open up the jars for me
I want you to open up my balls of water
so I don't crack my wrists as I do it
you can literally hear that in a past stream
where I've cracked my fucking wrist
opening a ball
hello everyone our little prince
a little T-Rex
R
hi I'm sorry for all the noises I made
I'm exhausted
sure but for real yes mummy I'll do anything
so the prince's treatment is fine
yeah honestly
you were strong in the game there's like
one called thigh rider
oh we'll do squattery wheel
and then we'll do thigh rider okay deal
my plan was just to go through the minigames
I wasn't going to start a campaign at the moment
I literally
so I got
an eight hour sleep I know a Christmas
freaking miracle I had to go with my dad I was like
dad look
that's like dad look between me and you
I'm going to be playing a game tomorrow
okay it's an exercise game
if you wake up between 4am
at 6am you're going to hear some noises
okay I'm playing an exercise game
it is a fun game it's wholesome family
friendly fun okay but I was like
between me and you dad
close your ears
I was literally
had to sell because we were
he was watching what was he watching
oh he was watching
this channel called like it's not the
outdoor boys he was watching this
this guy's autistic right
and he lives in a van
and he meets up with other people that live
in a van type thing
and we were watching him
and I was like oh you may enjoy the outdoor boys
bend your knees
oh point it down sorry
wait what do I do
am I just bending
press in
no can I make a
can I do what I think I can do
no no no no
you know what I want to make
come on
Nintendo don't ruin the fun
you know exactly what I want to make
alright we're doing it on the first one
oh wait I messed up
no it keeps getting bigger
why
no
that's not how it works
why is it getting bigger
oh my gosh
point your toes straight ahead
yeah my toes are pointing at a promise
a promise
no why
I'm trying so hard
replaying I'm trying so hard
it's just getting bigger
it's
cheating
I don't know
it's just getting bigger
oh oh we're getting the rounded edge
okay
okay okay hold it
ah come on
give me that give me that
I had to swap for that
I had to
swap for that come on give me that
give me give me yeah give me yeah
yes give me a flint thrower
nine points for a weenie
who's enough record it
I'll let the girls know what I need to do
I'm going to leave it like that
so when I add the girls and they play this game
they're going to be like
why did strongy get nine points
and then deep down we're all going to know
why I got nine points for that minigame
right okay make the vehicles jump
for tokens by squeezing your thighs
I can squeeze in another few things
I'm doing that boys
he he he
my Oshie making clay
but he's on stream for overall
okay you guys better be hydrating too
I've literally not seen one hydration emote
today don't think I got that for no reason
you need hydrate too
I'm not having it
right novice
let's see what we're looking at with these lugs
I guess when I didn't beat my heart rate of 180
believe it
oh ah
thank you for coming to member
we're getting closer to unlocking a new emote
use a chair
wait hold on thank
oh thank goodness I've got my fucking gamer chair
what I'm to use a chair for this
use a chair to help support
your weight no way I can tell
I just sat down how
stretch your spine straight
okay hold
the rank on between
your thighs so this is what
reeflings are you guys are a rank on
squeeze your knees together
press in to jump
okay
press in and hold
squeeze to hover
beanmeister
one month less more
thank you so much for the extended membership
right press in and hold
to hover
oh I don't have that kind of stress
my freaking thighs are going already
collect all the tokens you can
all the tokens you can
ready this is like really
unreactive
oh I don't have unlimited oh jeez
okay well I tried
right okay a spray instant
oh my god I'm like squeeze your abdominal
muscles
breathe deep
breathe deep after what you're
making me do this is like really unreactive
I'm having to like squeeze this out
like really hard
outstanding
alright
you should have got tails to voice this
be sure to extend your back
oh we hit the theory
does the game just end
as soon as I hit one of the bombs
hold on
awesome work
yeah this feels like cheating
because I'm sitting down
I'm not gonna lie
okay
oh there's more
no way
I feel like I'm gonna break the band
what
no way I was shy
the freaking thing I must have jumped off
yeah I was gonna say I didn't really
I got an A for that I was sitting down
I was sitting down
come on
I guess you guys
never get to see it
glad you're into it
I'll be taking yours
glad you enjoyed taking my super cherry
I'll be tasting yours
as compensation later
oh my god thank you Kaidon
Brian you're not supposed to actually
read that part out right that was really weird
sitting down walk forward
while extending and tilting the bar
to collect the tokens on the
side waist back and abs
well I don't really want abs
speaking of abs
a zero
more like abs are up
oh
oh thank you
thank you
okay hydration check to make sure all is good in the world
scrawny abs
absolutely not I'm here to be
curvy I'm here to be women laugh
I'm here
I have the pear
so I have to have my pears
still got the symbol ready I do
I have a strandig I bought it
to make sure I do all my emotes
and stuff like this stuff
you can hardly see it from here but yeah
oh god
am I crying hold on any
am sweating am I crying
I don't have a sweat I just bit sweat
you can hardly see the sweat
but I'm just going to leave it on
literally I spent
how many extra bucks to get a moat should I use like one which is the head motion
toggle. Right I'm gonna move the chair out the way because I don't think I need it
again. But if I need it she's right there. I'll get a chair I'll just keep
her to see. Lick up Moomi's straight. Sweat Gintu's strong raw. Peer body best
body. I'm hydrated by looking your sweat. No my sweat would be salty that's right
that's where I lose my soul. I'm gonna need refling, I'm gonna need something
that helps me replenish my salt levels. Huh huh huh come on it's too easy to make these
it's too easy it's too easy sorry it's too obvious. Right what are we doing? Stop
getting me distracted with your foolish ambition. Where do you play Elden Ring
actually? Whoa! Rotate the joycon to the left and grip it into your abs. Oh god.
Press it into your abs to hold. It's a joke. Press it and hold against your tummy.
Okay this hurts. Well pressing in your stomach lean. Okay.
I guess the other way. Oh no I can't do abs and I can't do arms. No I'm gonna be
sick. Hold on I need a burp. Oh that wasn't a good one. That wasn't a good burp
refling. It has been a worse result. And he walked up to the hill and he
marched him down again. What? I don't think I get it. Actually. Ready? Not really.
Go! Oh the grand old jerk of york. He had ten thousand men. He marched them up to the
top of the hill and he marched them down again. Oh when they were up they were up.
And when they were down they were down. And when they were only half way around they were either up or down.
That is a British chant for you. There you go.
Okay I got the 300. This is the worst one ever. Oh no. Can we go a bit more to the right?
Hey hey hey. Hit him with a hey hey. Okay hold on. I'm on a tamer. Why did I hear
tamer noises? I'm getting nervous. I'm sweating. Why did I hear tamer noises? I don't see a tamer.
So I'm actually jogging on the spot right now. I am not losing to tame. I'm not
losing to tame. I refuse. Okay this is it. Hey that was a really unique one.
Shawnee didn't you get the lyrics right? Like how dare you? How much does everyone
reveal their way? We used to be the biggest. Emmie, Tiny, Aisy, Tiny, Mercy, Nex,
Shawnee, Nex. She beat Nex. Azura can be as big as a skyscraper because she's a
goddess. So good luck measuring her. Oh my god. I had to do that off the top of my
head. No. Oh I didn't. Why would you not let me. Oh whatever finish. Whatever. If you
screw up the coins to spawn. I didn't even grab them. The tamer is just for our coin
points. Oh well. You know what we should play Wii Fit. That Wii Fit game. Like on that
board. And you stand on the board and the things that you fat bastard. And you guys can
know my real weight. Like whenever someone's like oh how much do you weigh? Whenever I tell
them they're like I don't believe it. You don't look as heavy as that. And I'm like yeah
it's all in the dumpy. Thank you. I'll be here all week. You have your strength at high
by the way. I do? The best way I can describe your body would be when Shawnee and Ruben
Esk curvy all over. I don't even know what that means. What does Ruben Esk mean? You're
using English and I don't know. Right core crusher. Right we'll play all the minigames
and then I think we'll do a running one. Wait why did that not work? Oh the things sideways.
That's why it didn't work. The things sideways after that game. I don't know why they did
it that way but sure sure. Right we'll do all the minigames. And then we'll let's get
to it. It's in the dump truck. I'm gonna need proof of that. You'll get proof in October
all you need. Everything you need baby. Wait what? Rotate it to the left again. No I hate
these ones. I'm gonna squeeze out a fart at this rate. I'm just pushing against my stomach
and my stomach goes at any fart. While pressing into your stomach twist to the right. Oh my
headset's getting away. Now release the tension while pressing in on your stomach. What is
this? What is this? Smash all the robots. Be careful of the robots with your shield. With
your shield. What? What is this? Go. Relax and then press and hit. And relax, press, hit,
relax, press, hit, press, hit, relax, hit, relax, hit, relax, hit, relax, hit. Sorry I'm having
to say it. I'm having to say it. I'm just saying it out loud. I'm just fucking aware.
Oh I'm relaxed, relaxed. It's like Kegel exercises but worse. Relax, relax. I'm like freaking
Breville in.
Your shield is rubbish.
Relax, relax. Reflex, relax. Just let it happen, relax. Oh my god.
Oh that was a hard one. Quit feying me, reflet. My god. Oh I need to sit down after that one.
Oh I'm sitting there on my chair.
Oh my god that was so hard. I had to like freaking remember. Are you squiddin' me right now?
Thank you.
Why? Anon would like to ask. Wait what was my heart rate? 186? Okay. Heart rate record.
186. Let's go.
Okay. Anon would like to ask. Hi Stroni. I was wondering when it comes to running.
Are you a sprinter or do you run for endurance? And I don't either. Like do you care about how
fast you are or how far you're going? I'd like to compare workers. You know you see I am a dwarf
from Lord of the Rings. I'm great short distances and by short distances I mean less than 100 meters.
I am a cyclist and I am a walker. I am not a sprinter. So when we get to the sprinting stage
we're gonna do a level that requires sprinting. You are going to hear how much I do not sprint.
Okay.
Okay. Our heart rate record is 186. So we think we can beat it. I don't know.
Need to go cycle. Like I can cycle fine. Cycle and I have no issues with. Right. Uh sure record it.
Why not? To Stroni. Not to be confused with uh I don't know something else that you could confuse
with. Um right gulting wait get lit-utting gallery. Lean left and right to avoid the
bomba. So we've got three more minigames and then we're going to do jogging. Are you ready for the
jogging? Ha ha ha. Gonna do jogging there. Right get lit-utting gallery. Wait as in gluttonous as
in you fat bastard. Did the game just call me obese? What the fuck? 186 feet per minute. That's
right you can see it live here folks. You know what you've never seen a hyperactive heart before?
Well now you have. Now you have. That was me slapping my thighs by the way.
I'm not uh I'm not doing Mario Kart tomorrow. We're playing Suica or Suqya. What do we do?
What have you stumbled into? Just the most suspicious noises a woman can make that isn't
suspicious at all. You've got quick circulation. What can I say these? Oh no it's an arm one. Oh no.
Okay that's fine I can do that. Oh I'm gonna burp again but not the good kind.
Oh that's a vomit kind of burp. Would you still love me if I vomited up all my water from this morning?
No you're glutes meaning your ass. Collect all the tokens. I'll try my best. Ready?
You pronounce it gluting as in your glutes. Oh glutes! Glutes maximum. Oh I get it now. Okay that
makes sense. I thought I was calling me gluttonous and I was like excuse you. Why do you think I'm on
the video game in the first place? Gluttonous based on... Clean to the side as you breathe out.
Clean to the side as you breathe out. I'm leaning, I'm leaning, I'm leaning, I'm leaning, I'm leaning.
I like this one. This is so easy. I'm just standing on the spot.
I said it too quick. I shouldn't have said anything. The bombs were too much.
Thank you time to say me for telling me the right title. You didn't have to pay me to do that though.
You could have just typed it in chat. You guys when you're flipping to put on a bug my hips are
like cross the bullet for it in real life as well. Like I don't need to lean with my hips but I'm just
just to prove how curvy I am. Oh look at the week 2 E birds as well. Oh they're so beautiful.
Can I get so big? Oh my first perfect. Let's go. Leave it to me. Record. Yeah I'm going to rub it in
the girl's face as I got perfect. Me telling them hey when you guys play this game you need to do
the minigames for no particular reason just so I can like rank them all. Do you use bike for
exercise or leisure for transport? So I get healthy from it. Anon. Anon in this says,
Strony. Paint you an audio idea. Strony pulls the thigh muscle after pushing herself too hard from
her workout and asks for response to help stretch out her muscles to relieve the pain with the
massage. I think you can see where the rest of it's going. Hey hey hey. Hey hey hey. That's
literally a Zura's most recent audio thing. We think of like Anon because I literally wrote that
for a Zura. Roughly. And I say has one coming out as well actually. It's my brat's irresistible thighs.
You're welcome OGsans. I know exactly what you all want to hear for the most part. Yes my
scripts are shit but in general I know what you want to hear. Right what's my heart rate? Okay I'll
wait until it goes down to 140. Okay let's sit down for a moment. Why did it go up? Why is it whenever
I say what's my heart rate? My heart gets nervous and like jumps up. I'm sitting down to give myself
a second. I saw the stream get some sleep and well. Res well thanks for hanging. At least you
aren't taping glorp your giggle stick bro. Hey y'all. Has mummy pushed herself hard? She's been behaving.
186 beats per minute. So for every second my heart beated twice and then some. Roughly. Then some.
We are reaching 175. Break core. That's so good.
Strony sweat rack. Thank you for the tip. Hi Strony make sure to work up a good sweat and then you
can use me. Clean it up once you're done. Well I was gonna see if I can give myself a round of
applause at the end of stream. Uh if you know you know. You know I just thought we could. Your
scripts are now. Your scripts are now giggle sticks by like them. I mean AC was like AC got
back to me and she was like I really liked how simplistic the way your scripts were written
in comparison to the script master and I was like right I'll send them a message. I'll tell them
you know to copy the way I do it. Um for the most part. Uh mummy ain't gonna have the energy to jump.
Okay we're 130. Okay I went up because I noticed it but it's just because my heart rate is so shy
okay. She doesn't deserve such things. Right whoever said exercise doesn't take up time.
I'm already exhausted and we're not even hit the 50 minute mark. I said what I said I'm exhausted.
I we're gonna get any more armpit audios. Um from Emmy in the video game maybe.
What was that? That was just a silly. With your elbows swing too slow. Okay hold on hold on let me
take my headset off. The body headsets wires in the way. I'm getting obliterated right too slow.
What? With your elbows at the side swing it.
What is going on? Bro give us a. The guy is stalling out. Is that all in? All right I'm just
gonna do that thing. I'm actually looking for. With your elbows at your side swing. I can't swing
that fast. I'm not even. Who played this game more? This is shit.
I'm getting absolutely rolled in a freaking exercise video game.
That was awful. Go do that again. Smack all the discs.
That was awful. I'm thinking I'm gonna get sunwalked in a freaking exercise video game.
I'm just fucking doing this. I'm fucking swinging.
I'm swinging. With your elbows at your side twist your upper body.
Oh yeah you like that. Okay I'll fuck it. Wait they take points for me missing even though
the game makes sense. I'm freaking swinging yeah. You can literally see by my model I am swinging
on the spot right. My ass meat is jiggling.
Oh forgiveness sake. Bro I'm actually getting sunwalked.
I'm getting sunwalked in a freaking exercise video game. Oh come on me. Come on give me a shot.
Oh come on. Fuck off that was the worst game we have played by far.
And I got a bravo for that. I'm right. That was awful. My ass meat is what jiggling.
I was going left and right and I could feel it. I'm moving and I was like excuse me.
Strongly barefoot. I wouldn't game with freaking shoes on. Are you serious?
I had a game with shoes on. We should not get in the spring a lot. Right last mini game.
And then we're going to do running and I will show you how pathetic my running is.
The treadmill. Oh this is the running game mode. Control your running speed to move
left or right on the treadmill and gather tokens. What?
Oh it's good though. It's good. Next time jiggle him up.
Yeah I ain't killed down before this next runner one because if it's about like
but running my heart rate is going to
explode. At over 180 my heart was beaten three times per second. Oh yeah you're right 180 divided
by three is 60. Yeah. Yeah. Oh that's so cool. My heart was beaten three times per second.
Boom boom boom. So literally boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom. That's what my heart
was doing. Are you squiddin me right now? I'm so smart.
I don't know. I don't say it's so strong. He likes guys with a little bit of chop in their stomach.
I like fat boys. Give me fat men. Hey Tony. I want to feed you. I want to rub your belly
after a hand feed you. Get like sit on your lap. Spoon feed you. Maybe like take away or something.
Then I rub your belly afterwards. And then I R word you.
Architect oh she. And don't worry if you're a beanpole apparently that's the terminology
which I found absolutely hilarious when you guys taught me. If you're a beanpole don't worry I'll
fatten you up. We'll hold you to that promise.
Actually apparently skinny guys are called beanpoles. I'm gonna find out the funniest thing I've ever
read in my life. Wait does Stroney live in a gingerbread home? No I'm not a witch. Are you
serious? The witch that makes those wainzy candy sweets and that? No I'm not a witch.
Stroney's laughing at me. I'm not laughing at you. Are you a beanpole? If you're a beanpole don't
worry. Just order take away. It's fine. I'll make you some of my treats.
What if you're kind of average? Then it's easy to put weight on you. Smile. Do you not know how
architecture works? I'm Hansel Maxing. Oh that's so good.
Okay right enough stalling. Do the next exercise. You lazy lazy switch.
Or say full of poet. I'm not a squid. I'm a skunkish. You're facts right.
Right I'm standing up again. Let's see how much my heart rate goes up because I stood up.
Oh we're in the 30s.
I know it's my time and I'll be. It's so far over for me. I need at least 10 years in film
dad bod ready. I can make it happen. I don't know. Give me like eight months. I think I'll get what I want.
Okay are you squidding me right now? Just slow point the ring there. If we run ahead and
lead you with a leash would you run faster mama? Would you run faster? Wait what if we run it?
Sorry my headset is currently hitting the microphone. You stop that young man.
What do you say Kaidon? If we run ahead and lead you with a leash would you run
faster? If you run ahead. No I don't like running. I don't enjoy running. Don't make me run.
Walkies fine. Absolutely fine on walkies. Running? No. I won't burp again. The water's coming back.
But not the good kid. I think I actually am going to be sick if I'm not careful.
Oh I just threw up in my throat.
Oh dear. What did I do?
And that was pure stomach acid in my throat.
All right I'll tell, I'll make you a deal. We'll finish this one and then we'll have a bit of a
break. Oh I just threw up. What did I do? My whole point is a true mistake exercise and I can't.
All right give me one more, give me one more chance okay? Clean it out. Ready? What am I going to do?
Okay I can do this. I can do this. Just one more, one more.
Wait how did I go backwards? I just stopped running.
Oh my gosh. Are you squidding me right now?
No she's just going to be like an English bulldog. Lying down and not moving.
Wait I'll check it out. That's a return assist. Wait how did I make it so I'm only in one leg?
Oh my god. Wait what? Jump. Okay okay and then stop running? Oh this is confusing. It's not late.
What the fuck? Right I need to do like an actual dog in one. This is terrible. I can't, I can't leap.
What the? What am I trying to achieve right now? Jump. Okay and then no stop.
And then go forward again. What the? This is the worst game mode. Okay this is the second
worst game mode after the other one. I can't maintain a lane. It keeps putting me a header behind.
It won't let me maintain a lane. It doesn't matter what it does. You need to control your speed?
How? It wants to constantly put me ahead. I'm trying.
Oh my god. They're only having to attack.
Hold on, hold on, hold on. No we need to do like the walking ones.
And now jump. No forward.
I literally have to start and stop to try and aim for a lane because I can't maintain a speed. It keeps
like putting me ahead. Why is this so delayed as well? No and then it just stops me right before the
coins. Oh come on mate. Brav. Brav. Take a break. Keep a steady pace. Yeah good luck.
Without it I can't do anything. Oh I just dropped my open car controller. You mean that big expensive
piece of equipment? Yeah I just dropped that. What are you going to do then? All right finish, finish.
All right we've done the minigames. What are the other stuff that you can do? There's, there's butt
stuff. And then there's running. We'll run for, I'll take a break and then we'll run and we'll do the
butt set and then we'll do running and then I'll see how I feel because I legit did it. Okay there
we go. I don't sound like I'm halfway across the room now. Hi Refling. Thank you Momo Loh. No she
is just going to be like an English Bulldog lying down and not moving. Yeah apparently those dogs
are like resistant to going on walks or something. I don't know. I thought dogs enjoyed walks all the
time. You would get excited for the butt stuff. I don't know what you're talking about Refling.
You've done great yeah. I've not bet my record of 186 though. Shock and behavior. Shock and behavior.
Shawnee if you get so close after sweating what did he say? Abs incoming better not. I don't want
abs. I want curves. I want hips. I want soft. Please do not beat the record. I mean we might
be in the drawing section. Shawnee's trainer. Shawnee's trainer says you're such a good girl for
doing your exercise. Keep it up and you can get a special treat. No you're not turning into one of
those two. Nope. You guys had your way with me on the headset whilst I was in the convenience store.
I was trying to service all these customers. No serve the customers not service the customers.
Those are two different sentences in the English language. If English is not your first language
to service serve customers and to service customers are two different things. Please
be careful if English isn't your first language and you use those kind of. I'm so sorry.
I was not afraid in slip because I was servicing you guys in the break room.
Damn I'm a customer. Service maximum.
You're so goofy. The customers are reeflings all along and you service them? I mean I'm sorry
that was a fun stream. I really enjoyed it. I know it's such a boring game. I probably won't
play it on stream again but it was so fun. I cannot stay long since I'm at work but I hope
you're having fun and getting lots of water. I'm having so much fun. Thank you so much.
Thank you for the super chat as well. I cannot stay long. Yes have fun at work hydrate eat.
Are you from Ireland? Because Irish you were Maine.
Sorry to burst your bubble meat but I'm Scottish so yeah. Joke didn't land but nice try though.
Nice attempt but I am from Scotland. I'm from the other country that kind of sounds like that.
Yeah but it was a good one. I'll give you that. I was good. I mean I got a giggle but yeah I'm from
Scotland the other country. Bro ain't leaving scott free. Oh oh good one. I'm killing myself. No
no no no it's fine. I'm across the port. I'm literally across the river. It's not a river
it's a sea but I'm across the sea from Ireland it's fine. Honestly I enjoyed the supermarket stream.
I wouldn't mind doing it again. Ink on this reefing right now.
I Scottish you were Maine. That's not even a sentence. What's going on here?
Scottish or Irish? First one to move is gay. Do you really love us? Do you not stick around for
the big watery kiss that I do at the end? Who goes there? Gremble and Anon. Are you squid and
mary though? If Stroney is an architect then call me the job site because I want to be worked on.
No way that is so good. Thank you for giving me your super cherry. Your super chat cherry not your
super cherry Jesus. Oh my god. Gremble thank you and Anonymous what did you say? Hearing you say
you like guys who got dadboards make me feel a lot better and gives us so much more self confidence.
I don't know I just always liked it. I don't know if it's because I like it. Are you squid and mary or whatever.
I just gravitate towards it. Yeah. I accidentally called you cunny struggles to a friend and now I
have to correct myself every time I say your name. The gap mo. Rika the gap mo if I had a
lollipop model and I sounded like this. I can't even imagine lightening my Scottish
voice. How did I even do that? Good morning everyone. Good morning everyone. Who's it going?
I'm Stroney Cattles the cunny of Vealour. The European. Oh no wait I see it's European.
Oh Vealour. I hope you're ready for another fantastic stream together. That's what you want.
No I can't lighten Max then. It doesn't work. It would be so good. The gap mo would be
perfect aggressive lollipop. No lightening just use the normal voice. Who's it going lads?
And I'm like in a tiny itty bitty body like Emmie. Well I tell you when Emmie was the first
model to be produced so I had to pilot her to make sure she was okay and hearing my voice come
out of this itty bitty adorable little thing and I'm just like how's it going right this is a test
I'm looking left I'm looking right here's an emotion test here's her crying here's her doing this
it was quite it was rather entertaining thank you Rika. I prefer mummy Stroney than lollipop Stroney.
Last cunny honestly that would be pretty good instead of do not pass go do not collect 200 bucks
the cunny stops yeah it sounds cunny enough welcome back lollipop get your drawers situated
I'm coming at you oh I've never heard that a sentence that should that should have been my motto
April first Vealour should just switch models do you know how expensive a prank like that would
be are you joking? Truly a dwarf experience. Stroney has piloted Emmie. I piloted everyone
did I not tell you the secret you know like the shorts that are on everyone's channels like the
early ones not the later ones not like the content ones obviously uh I'm I'm piloting their mix
the girls gave me voice lines and I created the memes for them so like I say doing the isotope
meme where she like blows up the fucking demon core that's me I made that I used her voice
it's me all it's all me but now the girls are starting to do their own stuff like as I said
like Mersey's most recent shorts I mean these are her on stream like you can't I can't you
pilot a mech when it's her on stream you know what I'm saying she was in every girl's body this is
the truest reason behind her HR absence the best mega pilot of all time the classic April
first joke is to switch models within me and stream on their channel I feel like that would hurt
their channel growth if someone's expecting like cute adorable AC and I pop up and I'm like hi dadas
and my fucking boys oh how's it going oh gee sands oh my voice is just a bit tickly I've got
we tickle in my throat the day are you joking me the oh gee sands would be writing they'd be like
get off the screen get off the stage get out of her account right now I was inside all the girls I
absolutely was there's nothing you can do about it uh reluctantly saying well we know you're all
six of them but we have to keep up the keep up honestly what are you talking about dadas
oh my dear bleeding my heart I can't wait to play this game with you
oh that would be hilarious Scottish face the last of the days I mean get on the maker or
strongly we'll have to go again maybe in the middle of the club so it's not too unexpected
explains why she has a muppet model do I look like a muppet to you
nah that's what they all do switch and impersonate if someone gets filtered by a joke skillet I
can't wait to play I can't wait to play 24 hours of league I mean honestly the problem is I think
she'd be would have to be me she's the only one that can come close to mimicking a Scottish accent
so I think it's already confirmed that she was going to be on my channel if we end up doing
a prank is always like that you talking like a zura is so good is it thigh grip oh what's the wrong
little rave ring are you getting your wires crossed I can't I can't guess right right let's do some
workouts for our gluteus maximus I've had enough of a break I know ironically kind of hope this
I think I would stop functioning if you left even for a prank I mean if one of the girls did go on
my channel I would just stream after they had finished having a go on me and then we can all
have a go on me at the same time you can't see it right now but I'm thrusting in real life I'm
literally spanking your arson your life I'm thrusting I just thought you should know I just thought
you should know the stream is going to be a limited ads will be worth it though
you come sweating over limit that sweat over channel termination that's different that's a
whole other ballpark you can play rhythm game you've not told me what to do right we're doing
squat okay white squat
okay let's move
two three five four all right five six seven eight
Wait, why does it not get full points?
You're amazing.
Oh, no, no, no, no, raise the arms.
This is how I'm going to throw up.
Oh!
Oh, I'm going.
You ain't got nothing on me.
Right, left, right, left, right.
I'm energetic. Are you joking me?
My knees are literally about to hit my nose in the game.
Oh, I'm supposed to bring down the broken arm.
I forgot to bring down the arm.
I just hold the arm up and point in front of you.
Oops, I didn't bring my arms down.
I'm so sorry.
I already got 100 points for that.
What?
One, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two,
1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, 1,2, I like this one.
I'm doing WHAAAT?
If you wouldn't need a screen, watch the example carefully.
What the hell?
What the heck?
Okay, I'm on the floor so I'm gonna try to make it open.
What?
What even is this?
Are you squeaking?
I'm on the floor.
Bend your knees, hold the ring, squeeze your knees together.
Okay, let's go.
Try this, work your butt out.
Oh!
Amazing.
Oh, take it.
Nice.
Take it.
Bend it.
Oh.
Great.
Five more.
I get this.
You're almost there.
Perfect.
Hold on for me.
Very nice.
Take it.
Good.
Ah!
Fine work.
You're fine.
Nice.
Well done.
Wonderful.
What?
Well.
You made it.
Oh my god, you took it so well.
It was fun.
That was insane.
You won't need a screen, just watch the example.
How is it gonna know?
Set the ring calm down.
Place both hands on the floor.
Extend your legs behind you.
Okay, I've done that.
Ah!
Are you squidding me right now?
Are you going to fart?
Are you serious?
At some point, we are going to hear
the Lego dismantling sound effect.
That was super energetically.
Oh, we're doing better.
Oh!
I've been doing better.
Right, right, right.
Don't forget to breathe.
I can do it.
Do it.
This is what we're training for.
We're doing fine.
Get in that ear.
It's the wide breath.
Right now!
Ah!
Left.
Right.
You made it.
Ah!
Time for a break.
No!
I want more.
Give me more of the reflame.
Okay.
I think I can do better than that.
Sorry, but I do.
Oh, I did it.
I think I can do it.
I want an A.
Sorry.
I messed up on one of the exercises.
Let me breathe for a second, though.
I should see the little,
just see catch my breath and we'll go again.
Okay?
It's fine.
Fine.
I'm back.
If only there was a 3D model.
Oh, boy.
I have good news for you.
If you keep supporting the girls on Patreon.
Okay.
Let me just lower the old heart rate.
I'm guessing I didn't beat my record though.
Thank you Anonymous for the tip again.
You did not get a perfect,
the sound quality of the thighs.
Could you hear me thumping?
I don't know which one of us will need a break after this.
Mommy is a huge, you know, word.
We were like, didn't we say?
And he goes, dear Lord,
she's gone, run fellow replings.
I'll hold her back.
I wouldn't everyone be fighting to hold me back.
I have some water.
Thank you.
Oh my God, my little voice is cracking.
I was so fun.
I like that one.
We're doing that one again.
I want an A.
Oh, I said what I said.
The wreathlings will hold Johnny back
so that the snowberries can escape.
The snowberries will try to escape into A.C.'s room.
What are you talking about?
Try to run that train.
Everyone would be volunteering to hold you back.
It'd be like the Monty Python scene.
I can take some peril, please.
Just a little bit of peril.
Running, yes.
Running the strunny.
Everyone would stay behind no exceptions for,
I am the only one that needs to be held back
and no wreathling left behind.
We all stand together.
Absolutely ogre.
Right, we're going to retry that one
because I really like that.
I like that one.
I think we can get an A.
I don't know if we can get full points
but I can do better than that
because I didn't realise with the arm
when I was supposed to go.
I mean, yeah, literally this is the first exercise
I've had since debut.
If you don't count cycling to the shop,
then she can't outward all of us.
Are you sure about that wreathling?
Literally, my only exercise was walks.
My dad took me to a cafe yesterday
and I cycled to the shops to get stuff.
That's all I've done.
Yeah, I thought that's about, oh my God.
Yeah, I'd like to find out.
All right, then you're on.
Fuck it.
All right, let's name a convention.
Where and when?
Once a week ring fit stream
so mommy doesn't become frail and weak, honestly.
I melt every time you do that.
It's unfair.
Aw.
Are you scared me right now?
Thank you for becoming.
Thank you for the extended membership.
Love you, love you too, love wreathling.
I appreciate the support.
It keeps the fun times coming.
Johnny, how much for the sweat
pouring off your body right now?
Ah, squid mirror.
I'll eat that, I'll eat that.
You didn't melt under the sunlight?
No, Violet-san, I didn't.
Thank you for the super chat.
I don't know, it's winter.
There's no sun.
How the hell can she still be at ease
even when she's out of breath?
Ha, I'll be on my death bed like,
please just make them ink one more time.
And then the poor attendant
that's been wiping my ass for six months
because I'm in a care home is gonna be like,
what the fuck is she on about?
Thank you, Violet-lover, for the super chat.
But no, I don't melt under the sunlight
in Australia because there's no sun
because it's winter.
It's summer for pretty much everyone else.
But the hemisphere flips it, okay?
So it's currently winter for me.
Looks like my name is Funtimes, though.
Or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or, or,
the brain was kicking in.
Shona on her hospital bed, please let me hold it.
I think that video is like 90K views or something,
it seemed like that.
I'm like, can you guys make one of the girls' meme videos
have that much views?
That'd be great.
Funtimes, I can't believe y'all got snow.
Or, or, yes, humid AF, it sucks.
There you go.
You know who else sucks?
She was a certified refling milker to the very end.
That is so good.
She's tickling something already and I ain't my tummy.
I mean, if I go in the back door,
it will be your tummy from the inside out.
Let's try this again, let me stand up.
Hold on, let me stand up.
I am going to try hard, so before anyone's like,
clippable, clippable, no, we're tryharding.
We're tryharding.
I'm taking my headset off,
that's how much of a tryhard I am.
My hands are off, your turn.
Okay, let's go.
One, push out your chest and keep your back straight.
One, I am, well done.
We're tryharding, come on, fantastic.
Right, amazing.
Good, wonderful.
Okay, keep it up.
Very nice.
Maintain the hard work.
Six, five, four, three, four, three, two, one.
Amazing, one, left, okay.
Okay, okay, perfect, perfect.
Okay, okay, let that heart be pumping.
Raise both arms, okay, okay, nice.
Both arms are raised, that repeat.
Move, super energetic.
One, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one.
Left, left, right, left, right, left, right.
Left, can help with abdominal training as well.
Left, 20 more, halfway there.
Right, left, right, left, right, right, right, right, right.
And then you get 100, and then you get 100.
Right, left, right, left, right, left, right, left, right.
Good, stay focused.
Bring me this combo.
I promise I'm doing it right.
No, no, no, no, no, I promise I'm doing it right.
Please let me don't do that.
One, two, one, two, one, one, two, one, two, one, two.
One, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two.
One, two, then your arm up.
One, two, one, two, worry about it.
One, one, one, two, halfway there.
One, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two 10 more
Two, one, two, one, two, one, two, one, two, five more
Two, one, two, one, two, one, one two
Half lip
Okay, let's move!
Breathe out when you lower your glutes.
Okay!
Perfect!
Yes!
Nicely done!
Find work!
Sharp!
Well done!
It's too bad!
Meet!
Fantastic!
Nice!
Excellent!
Meet!
Fantastic!
Nice!
Excellent!
Fantastic!
Nice!
Very nice!
Nicely done!
Great!
Five more!
Amazing!
Okay!
Three!
Excellent!
Awesome!
Okay!
Amazing!
One left!
Nice!
You made it!
One more!
I can do it!
Runners!
Please register!
Move super energetically!
Left!
Right!
Super energetically!
Left!
Right!
Halfway there!
Left!
Right!
You made it!
I'm done!
Let's go!
Oh, gosh!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Okay, let me get my chair.
Oh.
Are you squidding me right now?
I don't need.
That's all I ever wanted.
Did I beat my heart rate record?
Oh, I'm gonna throw up.
I hope not.
Oh, that's so good.
Oh.
I am so out of it.
No.
I didn't.
I didn't beat my heart rate.
I squint my heart rate.
Are you joking?
Good job, mama.
You did amazing.
Now let us give you a nice little massage
all over your body to relax you.
I need a moment.
Hold it.
I am so waiting.
Are you fun?
I'm actually covered in so air.
I'll reach the bridge out
in just a moment.
I need a moment.
I need to recalibrate.
Oh, moment.
You're so close.
Just one.
Maybe I'm shy.
I feel like throwing up.
That's your body telling me to pump down.
Okay.
I think we're okay.
Don't wanna throw up.
Oh.
Are you squinting me right now?
I will read another one.
One more.
Mommy needs some.
Oh.
I feel sick after that.
I went all low.
I don't know if you can tell,
but I went all low on that.
I'm not doing anymore.
That's me done.
I will feel very well right now.
I'm gonna be honest.
Is she beyond?
I'll see if I can redirect into Shiba.
I think I need to lie that.
I went too far.
Oh.
Where's my Shiba?
Shiba.
Wow.
I'm currently,
my body is trembling
and I don't know what that means.
Shiba's on the,
oh, she has,
she has, she's gone.
I think she's in her,
there is.
What?
Me?
No, no, no,
there is.
No, there isn't wrong with being a hag,
but no other ages.
I went too hard.
Are you guys okay if I redirect into Emi,
who's a couple of hours away?
I think I need to go lie down.
I don't feel very well after that.
Thank you.
Narrow, anonymous, anonymous.
And Seida,
who's a membership.
No, 30 minutes.
I mean,
Shibi's on holiday.
She's not here.
Are you okay?
Yeah.
I'm going to end.
I'm so sorry.
I don't feel very well.
I'll see you next time.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Love you.
I'll be okay.
Don't worry about me.
Yeah.
You're getting redirected in Emi.
She's a couple of hours away,
but she's there.
Sorry, Reflames.
I'm sorry.